there's a great david korn piece in
mother jones about Russia's involvement
in the 2016 election and the eventual
election of Donald and yesterday or the
day before the director of the NSA
Admiral Michael Rogers was asked about
WikiLeaks releasing hacked information
during the campaign and the this is the
NSA director okay this is not the
Hillary campaign or whoever else you
wanna pull a quote from the NSA director
said that this was a quote conscious
effort by a nation-state to attempt to
achieve a specific effect this was not
something that was done casually this
was not something that was done by
chance this was not a target that was
selected arbitrarily this is a stunning
statement what the NSA director is
saying is that Russia directly
intervened in the u.s. election to
achieve a specific desired end
presumably the undermining of confidence
in the United States by the election of
Donald Trump and/or putting someone in
as president of the United States that
Vladimir Putin could as as I said
earlier this week early last week play
like a violin which I believe indeed
Vladimir Putin would be able to do to
Donald Trump clearly this is a very
specific accusation from a government
intelligence official that another
country has impacted the sovereignty of
American elections by strategically
meddling this should be front page news
Pat this should be not only
behind-the-scenes investigations but
formal congressional inquiries with a
report at the conclusion of that
investigation it should be the breaking
story on every media outlet but it's not
the fact that another country is
meddling in American elections
successfully is barely making headlines
and when you look at what ruined Hillary
Clinton's chances is it was what about
what came out from WikiLeaks in the past
month
yep the campaign cycle things like the
John Podesta emails and things like her
speeches to Wall Street and I think a
lot of people looked at that saw Hillary
Clinton as corrupt in the same old
politicians we want to get rid of
chose Trump as the lesser of two evils
now I you know Pat and the audience
knows if they've been listening that
while I believe that those were factors
which led to the ultimate electoral
defeat of Hillary Clinton the much
broader problem was the fact that the
entire DNC primary pre-selected Hillary
Clinton a very flawed candidate who had
significant liabilities anybody could
have predicted that Republicans were
going to try to make a big deal out of
this could we have known that Russia was
going to get strategically involved in
order to further take advantage of those
liabilities and exploit them well maybe
maybe that was predictable maybe it was
and it certainly wasn't being discussed
but you're absolutely right that it had
an impact whether or not whose fault
this is is sort of a different issue but
there's no doubt that it had an impact
we need investigations into this and
these intelligence investigations often
remain secret it's often classified
information that keeps them that way but
we have allegations here from the NSA
director that a foreign government has
been messing around and undercutting and
undermining an American presidential
election how can Americans be secure
about the foundation of the country and
trust the government if another
country's government is directly
influencing election results and we've
seen Democratic congressman Elijah
Cummings we've seen some others say hey
the FBI needs to investigate these links
Senate Minority Leader Harry Reid has
done the same I don't know what's
ultimately going to happen that that I I
don't know what could ultimately come of
these investigations and there is a huge
difference between an FBI inquiry that
happens only behind the scenes and a
full-blown congressional inquiry with
open hearings and a report we need to be
doing that and when we talk about
American sovereignty that has to include
foreign influence on our elections now
there's a major major difference people
might hear me say this and they'd say
but David uh the intentions of other
countries and geopolitics of course it's
going to be relevant to an American
election that is very different than a
foreign power specifically taking
actions to influence American voters
we're talking about very very different
things and any time we talk about the
NSA you know I'm no huge fan
the NSA right I mean the NSA initially
defended bulk surveillance by saying
it's prevented tons and tons of
terrorist attacks we found out that that
claim was totally false so I think it's
important Pat that we take everything
with a grain of salt but in this case
the statement from the NSA is only
corroborating what we've been suspecting
for a very long time and I'm sure
there'll be much more to do about this
if it was a foreign country like Saudi
Arabia or Iran interfering with their
elections a lot of people just don't
take uh what Russia does in the
atrocities that they commit very
seriously that's true I would argue that
Saudi Arabia does directly impact our
elections if you look at how reliant we
are on the world price of oil and how
tied in to that Saudi Arabia is I think
there's a good case to be made that
Saudi Arabia is making uh an impact on
our elections but not the type of impact
you're talking about that would make the
headlines were discussing this is insane
and unfortunately it's not breaking news
everywhere and it really should be this
is what we should be talking about
rather than as important as it is for
Trump to respect the the traditions of
the press going to a steak house in
Manhattan without notifying the press
pool but that's a different story that
maybe we'll have time for I've talked
about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is Zipcar which gets you
a car when you want it when you need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your zip
card each car share member reduces their
personal co2 emissions by between 1100
and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash david support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join Zipcar
dot-com slash David